[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday january 13th
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor on the show
kier stammer called on boris johnson to
resign yesterday should he i'll speak to
rod liddle and james forsyth
the prime minister says he won't be
doing anything until sue gray the civil
servant looking into the number 10
parties releases her findings jill
rutter herself a former civil servant
would join me to discuss what she might
say
meanwhile as one hundred thousand
russian troops are stationed at the
ukrainian border
delegations from moscow and washington
are meeting in vienna for crisis talks
what is putin going to do
owen matthews and dmitry alprovich will
be on the show
finally in a piece for the spectators
world edition mary harrington says covid
has exacerbated class divides and
created a new laptop class she'll be on
to explain
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv remember to subscribe to
our youtube channel click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode ever again and
why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too
you can get 12 weeks in the magazine in
print and online along with a free 25
amazon voucher for just 12 pounds just
go to spectator dot co do uk forward
slash tv offer to take it up
boris johnson has admitted that he was
at a party in the number 10 garden in
may 2020 even if he claims he thought it
was a work event
at pmq's yesterday kirsten called on the
prime minister to resign saying he was a
pathetic spectacle of a man rod liddle
in his column for the magazine agrees
and writes that the sooner johnson has
gone the better
james forsyth meanwhile in his cover
piece as well this might be one mistake
too far are we really seeing the end of
boris johnson rod and james join me now
rod in this week's magazine you find
common calls with the likes of kierstana
douglas ross the scottish conservatives
leader um in saying that ultimately the
sooner boris johnson goes the better and
what's brought you to this conclusion
well what's brought me to this
conclusion it's a rather moral
uh the rather pompous phrase that he's
lost all moral authority you could argue
that he'd lost all moral authority every
previous time he's lied but in this one
where it's so
patently clear and to such
uh
fury from the public
then i think it's all gone but i mean
the real reason he has to go is because
he's of no use anymore um
in that
boris's deal with the conservative party
is you know i will be incompetent and
boris-like but i will win you elections
but that doesn't look very likely at the
moment um he's miles behind in the polls
i think
the the lowest victories have been in
ten years uh behind labor so so that
thing which boris was had which is that
he could win the elections no longer
looks as if it's true the the counter
argument
i suppose
uh and what some of the conservatives
will cling to
is that whilst boris is incompetent and
lies reflexively and
seemingly every juncture
he gets the big things right such as
brexit such as winning in 2019 and
crucially you know and we ought to give
him credit for this uh telling sage to
get stuffed
three weeks ago you know all of those
were good decisions uh which i suspect
the public rather likes him for
but it's become outweighed and i think i
i just think his position is pretty much
untenable
and james that argument which um rogers
summarized is one that michael gove made
to tory mps this week at meeting the
1922 committee he was let's talk about
cladding and leveling up but gave a
speech saying on the big calls that the
prime minister is still right and that's
why he should have their backing do you
think that the prime minister does have
the backing of the majority of the
parliamentary party right now
i think the majority of the political
party right now
don't want uh the blood and drama of a
leadership contest
but i think they are sitting and waiting
to see
uh how the public reacts you know
rod's right the tory party's
relationship with boris johnson has
always been very transactional uh i
don't think the tory party would have
made boris johnson leader except in the
circumstances they were in where you
know they had just come i think fifth in
in in the european elections uh they
were polling very badly they looked to
be set for a kind of complete electoral
wipeout and you know as as as one uh
someone who's known boris johnson for as
long as rod bonds put it to me you know
victory party were only ever going to
turn to him when they were kind of
two-nil down with uh uh 15 minutes to go
and you know he was there their super
sub in those circumstances he came on uh
he won them a majority of a size but i
don't think any other tory could have
done
i think the danger of him now is if a
sense goes that he's moved from
electoral asset to liability then i
think you will see the ruthless side of
the tory party
rod boris johnson did offer an apology
or at least a part apology at prime
minister's questions this week and
saying he could understand why people
were upset um even if perhaps
technically just technically he still
believes he was within the rules did
that sway you at all um his apology
yes it swayed me in the other direction
that he should go even quicker
i mean it wasn't an apology it was a it
was a weasley little tony blair kind of
non-apology apology
in that he apologized if people were
upset uh so nothing to do with him he
apologized that there was that the party
could have been better arranged
maybe they should have had it inside
whilst always stating that uh
he hadn't broken any rules
you know it was it was a non-apology and
i thought for the first
three or four questions at question time
um kirsten got it absolutely right and
was rather good
and
i suppose the problem will come for
boris
when we find out the results of this
investigation
i think
uh the thing which may hasten the
conservative part of you and james will
put me right on this is
if it is found that boris
was technically not breaking the law
because of course
downing street is crowned property
but if that is the only reason that the
law wasn't broken then i think that is a
technicality which the public simply
will not swallow and i suspect tory mps
won't swallow it either
james do you agree that do you think the
report will be a pivotal moment i mean
it does feel as though for ministers and
the prime minister right now the
report's almost useful and because they
can just uh you know stonewall any
questions by saying just wait just wait
a few weeks
i think the report will
be quite factual and i don't i think one
of the reasons why um some of those
around boris johnson are so keen to kind
of emphasize the importance of the
report is
it's not the report's job to write a
sentence like the prime minister should
resign and i think that they will
hope to point to the fact the report
doesn't say that and say oh well he's
been cleared time to move on um
i think the difference between
this
uh report and civil servants are
understandably reluctant to look like
they are forcing a prime minister out if
you think of robin butler's reporting to
the intelligence around iraq's uh
weapons of mass destruction and how that
was used to make the case for war in
2004
or you know even lord gait's letter to
boris johnson about whether he broke the
ministerial code over the arrangements
for
redecorating his flat you know they they
they don't want to be the person who
looks like they have forced out the
prime minister because you know they
they are an unelected official
not an elected politician but i think
the difference between this story and
those stories is this is
a very simple story for the public to
understand this isn't about whether
intelligence should be triple sourced as
opposed to single source the difference
between human intelligence and signals
intelligence
it it's something much more simple and
something that people feel far more
viscerally and i think this is one of
the things that the tory mps are saying
is you know
that those rules in the first lockdown
were so strict that there that people
are kind of really furious at the idea
that uh the people in government who
were making those rules were
were finding ways um to stay within the
rules but do things that other people
weren't doing and i think that that is
that is where it is so dangerous for
boris johnson
rod one of the things that appears to be
keeping boris johnson safe or safer um
is ultimately the fact there is no
consensus right now and who should
replace him and therefore you wouldn't
really have a neat uh successor brought
in you could have actually quite a messy
contest is there anyone who has caught
your eye as someone who would do a
better job
yes julian cousteau the leader of the
social democratic party but him aside
and he's probably not in the running
katie at this point um
uh yeah i mean obviously uh i spoke to a
conservative mp this morning who told me
that there were 250 of his colleagues
who wanted boris out i mean he said 250.
um
uh and i
i think the the some of the press and
some of the commentators have gotten
into their heads that
there will be a kind of genial
coronation of rishi sunak
but there's quite a lot of people within
the conservative party who do not want
rishi sunak uh largely because of his
fiscal policies
and there are even more people in that
party who don't want lose trust uh for
various reasons um so i think you
probably i know james will probably
write and i'm sure knows his far better
than i do but my guess is that when a
leadership election does come along and
my guess is that it will come along
sometime within the next four to six
months you know uh that when it does
come along there'll be six or seven
people on there and the the great lesson
of conservative party leadership
campaigns is that the favorite never
wins
james do you think that they'll be able
to fit all the candidates in a potential
tory leadership contest in one room uh i
think there'll be no shortage of
candidates i think again as happened
last time there will have to be some
kind of winnowing process you know the
rules don't don't formally require
people to have a certain amount of
support but i think that that is what is
going to have to happen because you know
when you are in government you cannot
have a contest with 15 candidates at the
start of it uh i i think that will
undoubtedly be a contest i think that
you know i think there's a there's an
odd shocking um no one wants to be the
front runner into a leadership contest
for the reasons that rod says and i
think so much of these tour leadership
contests depends on the pres on the
timing the precise way in which this
thing starts um
i i think the but i think one of the
things i will say is that when parties
pick successors they always tend to go
for someone who is uh the opposite of
what went before so uh the tory party
went from uh you know if you go through
it from margaret thatcher's
domineeringness to kind of john major
with his desire to just kind of you know
whip's desire to kind of keep the party
together they went from uh the
smoothness of david cameron to uh
theresa may's very different persona
they went from theresa may to boris
johnson so i think the person who
succeeds boris johnson if there is a
leadership contest will be someone who
who feels very different to him in terms
of political style and approach
well indeed a good point james so in
other words they're probably going to
choose someone
competent and honest
rod can you think of anyone who had
fallen into that category
uh but can i think of any well you see i
i i always go with the crowd as a social
conservative therefore uh i quite like
uh
uh uh liz trust at the moment uh but
whether she i mean people become
people think that
that uh john major for example uh was
not a
a born leader a born prime minister but
and in fact in my opinion he turned out
not to be a terribly good prime minister
all either but uh we we don't think of
people
inhabiting that role until they actually
inhabit it um and so frankly it could be
pretty much anyone i don't know the
runners and riders i just hope it's
someone
who is a social conservative and who can
roll back a bit against uh
in the in the cultural war which i think
is one of the reasons uh an important
reason
why those red wall seats went to the
conservatives last time around it was
far less the attraction of boris and far
more
a thorough going dislike of the
anti-patriotic anti-patriotism and
wokeness of corbyn
now james we're talking about what a
potential tory leadership contest this
year would look like but perhaps you
could help us envisage the other
scenario um which is still possible
boris johnson has bounced back before
what do you think the scenario is where
boris johnson actually does get through
this and what does he then need to do to
secure his position if he can do
anything
i think the scenario when she gets
through this is the grey report is quite
factual it doesn't contain direct
criticism of him uh
he saw you know that there are
various senior heads in downing street
role on both the political and the civil
service side allowing him to say that
he's cleaned house tory mps decide to
stay their hand you know say look let's
wait until we see what the results these
may local elections are and then kind of
gradually can have other political
issues come to the fore cost of living
energy crisis
um
then you have the may elections they're
bad but they're not catastrophic you
know he says look this is kind of
classic midterm problems for the
government and we're coming out with
measures soon to help people with the
cost of living and you know it goes on
and
and it's worth remembering that you know
that that always one of the reasons why
uh party leaders and particularly prime
ministers survive
is that that their mps want to wait for
the kind of perfect moment to change
leader or the perfect moment to to to
trigger a contest
and there is never such a thing in
politics and that i think is the way
that boris johnson comes back and then
he starts to say look we got out of uh
covered restrictions before other places
because of the decisions that i took
and
he he can rebuild that way but i think
one of the things that will be difficult
for him is that even before uh this
story broke um
this year didn't look like it was going
to have much political good news for him
in it
given you know the squeeze on cost of
living from inflation rising energy
bills and all of those things and i also
think he's at that difficult phase of
his premiership where um
there is a at the beginning of your
premiership big statements so if he came
out and said we're going to turn around
every boat in the channel that rally
supports you once you have been in
office for as long as he has now
when you say things people are waiting
to see whether they actually happen
rather than just giving you applause for
what you say
and finally rod is there anything boris
johnson could say that would make you
change your mind then make you think
actually he is the right person to lead
the party
no i don't think so but i think i think
james is right and i think that
that's not an unlikely scenario that he
does continue to battle onward i mean i
think the main the many elections
are important if you
if you if they if they
reflect what the polls are saying now
which is that you know uh 36 of people
who voted conservative in red hall seats
uh will now no longer do so
then that puts a whole raft of seats up
for grabs especially where i am at the
moment in
two side uh virtually the whole of t
side or when conservative apart from
middlesbrough central
uh
once that happens then you do have a
whole bunch of very very nervous mps who
will be agitating for change as well as
those in the party
excuse me who would never terribly happy
with boris in the first case and
actually if you think about it
june july for a leadership contest it's
actually not a bad time for the
conservatives to do that
exactly mid-term but
you know you get a new leader in
honeymoon period things look good for a
bit you hold another election and
probably win it you know that's
that's the other scenario but i think
james's notion that that he may well get
away with it and just bluster on through
is quite possible
thank you rod thank you james
so the prime minister urged mps to wait
until sue gray the civil servant looking
into number 10 parties finishes her
inquiry so who is gray and what might
she say about the prime minister
i'm joined now by jill rutter a former
civil servant who is now a senior fellow
at the institute of government
jill this week is not just boris johnson
who we keep hearing about it's also
someone called sue gray and when a
politician doesn't want to answer a
question about various parties and the
frequent replies let's wait till sue
grey has finished investigating now sue
grey is a civil servant can you tell us
a bit about her
so sue gray is quite an interesting
person she's um a very senior civil
servant she's
uh her day job is as a second permanent
secretary
uh shared between the cabinet office and
michael gove's leveling up department
because she's in charge of relations
with the devolved government she
actually at the sort of times of the
lockdown it's quite interesting that
she's only just recently come back to
the cabinet office from northern ireland
where she went off to be permanent
secretary at the department of finance
um put her pat in the ring to be head of
the northern ireland civil service which
is separate civil service uh but didn't
get that job and so came back to london
but where she really
you know came to a degree of public
attention obviously nothing like now
is as director general of propriety and
ethics in the cabinet office where for
the cabinet secretary and successes
prime ministers she would investigate
dubious behavior by a variety of
ministers so for example
it was sue gray that put the kibosh on
damian green's career over
yeah his uh the investigation into him
so that's sue gray's track record so
she's been there done that in terms of
investigations before what she's never
really had to do before is do something
where the buck might very well end up
with the prime minister so that's a the
distinct awkwardness of this particular
investigation and of course he's only
doing it now because it was originally
tasked to the cabinet secretary simon
case but then ten days later he had to
recuse himself when it was revealed that
he might have been at a party in the
cabinet office
and as you say jill it's a very unusual
situation to have a civil servant
ultimately in charge of a report that
could uh really severely impact the
prime minister's position and therefore
there does seem to be some confusion
over how um bad this report could really
be for boris johnson and because
ministers have ultimately all said oh
we'll wait to this report boris johnson
has also said wait to this report before
you get there i think some think it
could say something along the lines of
you know boris johnson broke the law he
must go but that's not quite what we're
talking about is it what is it more
realistically going to say in terms of
the various scenarios
so the thing she was asked to
investigate was whether there were
parties because remember this
investigation was set up when that uh
video that the prime minister told the
commons he was shocked by the uh legra
stratton
video came out and the prime minister
had still been telling parliament that
there were no parties that guidance was
followed at all times
so uh sue gray's really trying to
establish the facts about were there
parties um
the interesting thing is how much
further does she go than that does she
tell us
she'd probably say some things about the
culture in number 10 and the way they
treated that does she go into
why did they think they were compatible
with the
prevailing guidance and rules at the
time we know the guidance rules are a
bit different sometimes so why do they
think this was okay
does she tell us anything about who were
the movers and shakers behind having
these parties
uh does she tell us anything about what
the prime minister
knew or didn't know i don't know how
narrowly or widely she'll interpret her
remit
i think she's in a really really
difficult position what sue grey won't
do though
is say
the prime minister must go
that really she will pass the ball over
to two p two different sort of sets of
people
one for the sort of fallout for any
civil servants implicated and criticized
in her report if she does that
then any disciplinary action doesn't
fall to sue grey it falls to simon case
as the head of the civil service
any fallout for the prime minister uh
she can't do that she's not going to say
boris johnson's got to go um basically
she'll have the report to the prime
minister the prime minister could decide
to refer himself
to lord geit or to the parliamentary
standards commissioner possibly
who can make judgments on whether he
breached the minister or code
um but really really really the
important action then
turns to the prime minister's back bench
colleagues
and his ministers in his cabinet do they
think
that based on whatever facts sue grey
chooses to expose and what evidence she
uncovers that the prime minister
uh can't go on and that's really for
them to determine so
yeah the problem for sue gray
is that she's really on a bit of a
hiding to nothing i think the civil
servant should never
accepted that it would investigate this
because at the moment she's a convenient
delaying tactic but the trouble is that
her report risks satisfying absolutely
nobody uh there will be people who say
the civil service is trying to get at
the prime minister we've had quite a
tricky period for relations between
ministers and civil service
and if you know it increases the
pressure on the prime minister people
will say well we always knew the civil
service didn't like this government very
much
uh if however it you know gives meat to
those who want to exonerate the prime
minister then she'll be accused of doing
a whitewash for her political masters so
i think it's in a really really
difficult position just shows why
actually she should never ask a civil
servant to investigate the prime
minister
and and as you touch on i mean we've
already seen jacoby smog the leader of
the house and talk about how if there
you know hr and a report ultimately
civil servants who should lose their
jobs um rather than politicians that
would not be the the right way about
going about things and before i suppose
we get onto potentially civil servants
who could be vulnerable i just wondered
one of the things that sue grey's report
could do is bring more evidence to light
put it in the public realm and
what access does she get will she be
able to look at things like cctv um
when it comes to for example that email
which was leaked um from martin reynolds
inviting staff to a drinks party that
would be something she has hold of but
what kind of teeth does she have when it
comes to getting information
so the interesting thing is that the
team is basically her old team
including the guy a guy called darren
tierney who's doing her old job as
director general of propriety and ethics
so what just changed was who was at the
top of the investigation
um but these aren't like super sleuths i
mean yes they will be asking people
uh
interviewing people uh asking them what
went on uh interviewing a lot of people
in number 10 i imagine
they may have asked for access anyone
has to memos whether people disclose
them or whether we find that the people
outside government actually have better
access than sue gray i mean it would be
really interesting to know whether she
knew about the 20th of may
party
in its full glory before it you know
dominic cummings sort of put it into the
public domain and that memo was
leaked to paul brand at itv we don't
know that um
i think when the real risk for su grey
is that people think that she's been a
bit over hasty and not got the full
information out but you know this isn't
a sort of police investigation uh it's a
disciplinary if you like investigation
to see whether
about behavior internally so it's more
an hr style investigation so she'll
depend it on you know people wanting to
cooperate with their bosses but the
clear message
from simon casey civil servants should
be that you have to engage with sue gray
and let her have all the information
that you have downing street as you say
does have sort of security videos we saw
that in the famous pleb gate
investigation into andrew mitchell that
those security cameras there but
is it that obvious i mean the people
working in number 10
uh she might be able to say when for
example at the famous 18th december
party the first party were there lots of
outsiders that booked into number 10
when you go into number 10 as you know
katie you have to sort of sign in you
know show your past be on a list
uh she might want to look at that but if
it's just staff in number 10
uh do we know that you know
are there photographs of people going in
you know handing big crates of booze or
whatever or did they just have a sort of
yo
few cans in their backpack uh a bit
difficult to tell and i know when i went
to number 10 i was always a bit
embarrassed about being caught on camera
going into number 10 with that week's
stash of diet cokes to get me through
the week so yeah i mean people do
work there as well as party there so
it's quite difficult in that sense to do
that so
um does she interview dorman i don't
know i mean you know it's up for her to
decide
how to do it and to balance i think
almost the need for speed
uh against the need for this to be
clearly a sort of you know thorough job
and sue gray
will also have an eye on her own
personal reputation i mean she'll want
to have been seen to have done a good
thorough professional and fair job
because ultimately a lot of job people's
you know future careers could be
blighted by what she says
uh so she has to be quite careful that
she is genuinely fair
to those
yeah and just and just finally um we
talked about how ultimately ousting a
prime minister is always going to be a
political decision but there are some uh
other figures martin reynolds um the
senior um
advisor to boris johnson civil service
who um ultimately
sent that email and and so do you think
we could start to see um civil servants
referred for um disciplinary or that
could be the perhaps the scalp for this
report
well that will ultimately be a decision
for simon case assuming of course that
simon case himself doesn't come in for
criticism in the report which is also
possible
uh i think you know
it'll be very interesting to see how
this place if there's absolutely sort of
unequivocal evidence that civil servants
in number 10
uh basically
indulge in sort of serial rule breaking
then i think it'd be very difficult for
them to stay there and indeed those are
the very people who should have been
advising the prime minister if the prime
minister would come down and said oh
it's a nice day you know
we should thank staff at a work event
outside and the civil servants hadn't
sort of advised what prime minister we
think that you know would look very
incompatible with the guidance that
oliver downes just about to tell the
nation about at the downing street press
conference i mean you know you would
possibly just criticize civil servants
even if their involvement was only that
if they were the movers and shakers
behind this and that's a that's a
different thing and i think on the test
for the civil service
is how does it handle that if something
looks the public like sort of really
egregious behavior but the civil
services
is to try and brush it under a carpet
and
just perhaps slightly sooner than might
otherwise have happened move that person
into the job they would have got anyway
then i think the civil service will
probably be criticized for not taking
this
seriously enough so i think there's uh
there's going to be quite a tricky
question the other big question i think
for number 10 and i don't know whether
sue gray will see that says within her
remember at all or not
is on what basis did the prime minister
give all those assurances
that the guidelines were followed at all
times because that really is one of the
big issues for the prime minister
notwithstanding whether he went to that
particular party or not there's also a
big issue about whether he
you know
misled parliament you can say
certainly looked a bit economical with
what he admitted to knowing about uh
given what has happened in number ten
and i don't know whether sue grey is
going to go into how number 10 handled
the questioning about this because
clearly they weren't at all forthcoming
until that initial video leak forced
their hand
thank you jill
away from westminster russian and
american delegations are meeting in
vienna this week with the two countries
looking to negotiate a solution to the
crisis in ukraine
one hundred thousand russian troops are
stationed on ukraine's eastern border
readying some expert state for an
invasion
in this week's magazine owen matthews
writes that putin's actions are
motivated by nightmares of revolution
rather than dreams of empire he joins me
now alongside dimitri alpovich a
security expert and founder of silverado
a non-profit in washington
owen in this week's magazine you write
that putin is ultimately worried about a
revolution can you go into some details
well he's worried about
revolution in general because revolution
is
being one of the biggest spokes in the
wheels of his foreign policy
because unfortunately
for putin revolutions have toppled
successive
uh governments most than pro-russian
in a swathe of post-soviet countries and
my my argument in this week's magazine
is that
the unrest last week in kazakhstan is
very worrying for future because
unlike for instance in georgia ukraine
armenia kyrgyzstan that have all
experienced the so-called colored people
power revolutions over the last couple
of decades uh those are all kind of
more or less chaotic democracies
kazakhstan is not a chaotic democracy
it's actually very similar to russia in
its political and economic structure
it's run by a small clique of
bureaucrat oligarchs it's been
systematically repressing its domestic
domestic opposition it
operates a russian-style type of uh
managed democracy as they call it
except that you know the management kind
of fella came unstuck for reasons that
uh um
uh western observers so far are not very
clear about but clearly there was a
extraordinary convulsion of violence
coming apparently from nowhere um that
um
certainly rocked the regime i'm not sure
we're not sure how close it came to
toppling the regime but certainly it
came close enough for uh the president
to actually call in reinforcements from
russia and other
former soviet states so my argument is
that that's worrying for putin because
if it can happen in kazakhstan then
perhaps it can happen in russia
dimitri do you agree with that do you
think um in a way perhaps has a
misreading sometimes when we read you
know putin is longing for an empire and
actually this is more of a defensive
action
so i i do think that putin wants to
recreate russia's fear of influence i
don't necessarily think he wants to
recreate the soviet union as it existed
back then
he frankly doesn't want to own
all these
states that are in many cases economic
basket cases
and endure russia with
the need to support them in fact there
was quite a bit of resentment in the
later stages of the soviet union uh
amongst russians that they were sending
all this money to support all the other
soviet republics and very little that
was coming back to help russia itself so
i don't think he wants to do that but he
clearly wants to make sure that russia
has a strong say
in foreign policy and to some extent
even domestic affairs of these countries
particularly when it comes to energy
policy that is of national security to
the to the russian federation
um on kazakhstan i have to disagree a
little bit with owen because i think the
the situation is quite a bit more
complicated um certainly you have the
protests that started on january 2nd
that were driven by economic demands for
change and corruption um and and seemed
to have been just spontaneous popular
protests but very quickly they turned
violent with
some very
shady characters showing up on those
protests taking over uh security
buildings setting them on fire taking
arms shooting at security officers
fairly accurately and and there's still
a debate going on on who exactly those
people were what their agenda was
one of the common theories is that these
were people that were actually allied
with
certain
security forces that were loyal to
nazarbayev the the previous president
who um
nominated his successor the current
president to kiev
but there's been um a lot of
friction between the two parties between
the chicago party who
um still had not full uh had not had
full control of the armed forces and
security forces even though he was
president and there was concern on the
part of the nazarbayev faction that once
nazarbayev dies he's um in his 80s and
has
a number of medical uh uh ailments
that their power would be lost so um it
appears that there there may have been a
coup attempt uh it appears that may have
been a coup attempt that was trying to
leverage the
popular protests
and frankly the way it turned down it
turned out is an unbelievable success
for putin because what ended up
happening is that putin with very little
cost and commitment sending just about
2500
troops into kazakhstan um and and now
appearing to pull them out so just a
about a week long deployment has managed
to one prop up to caive and uh secure
his hold on power and at the same time
pull him squarely into russia's orbit
where takaiv now owes putin in fact he
said that publicly and putin has much uh
better influence and control over
kazakhstan's
foreign policy than he ever did
previously under the azerbaij regime
they were focused on what they called
multi-vectoring uh trying to accommodate
the interest of russia china and the
west
now it's going to be squarely single
vectoring
much of it towards russia and owen what
about the situation in ukraine because
um you've spoken previously about this
and um there was lots of speculation
that russia can move in and come january
and
u.s and russia are holding talks this
week
um
are we seeing a sign of putin ramping up
or not so much
well i think um just to pick up on a
very important thing that dmitry just
said is
dimitri believes and i also believe that
putin wants to restore his fear of
influence but does not want to restore
the empire now that's actually an
enormous difference it's really very
crucial in understanding this and um
this is a
situation that could very easily spiral
out of control but i firmly believe that
the evidence points to
the military buildup as a kind of heavy
metal diplomacy and not the prelude to
a
serious invasion and the reason i
believe that um is uh threefold one is
that actually um there's
there are very few scenarios by which
actually putin can actually achieve
something useful to him um with um a
ground invasion particularly not where
in the part of
ukraine where the troops are massing
which is in fact on the ukraine
belarusian-russian border which is
actually just north of kiev um it's
nowhere it's not actually not on the uh
disputed uh rather on the separatist
territories
i mean clearly um putin is actually
trying to in my opinion make a point and
actually force nato to come to some
decision and that's about uh its
engagement with ukraine and i think
that's the beginning and the end of
putin's uh strategic ambitions there i
mean there's he's he's very forcibly not
absorbed the breakaway republics of
eastern ukraine i mean if he wanted more
territory if he wanted more empire he
could have done that he hasn't done that
he's had some inside ukraine to be a
sort of pain in the side of the um of
the ukrainian government basically
forever
putin's agenda is different
to putin nato expansion is not the
solution to the problem it's the cause
of this problem it's a dialogue of the
death
ukraine lithuania poland all these
countries that had very understandable
historical traumas with the russian
empire and the soviet empire are all
saying he wants to invade ukraine we
need to accept ukraine into nato but i i
believe that actually that's the
opposite of the truth
is that in fact it's the engagement of
ukraine of of nato with ukraine and
particularly the deployment of uh
military advisers and um and lethal
technologies in in military u.s military
aid and so on that's actually the
problem and putin is actually just
trying to do essentially what john f
kennedy did in 1961 and the uh sorry in
1962 during the missile crisis uh you
know and just saying you know you cannot
come to our doorstep our backyard with
your with your missiles ukraine is the
step too far that is a absolute threat
to our russians
to our essential national security
interests and you're not going to do
that that's his point i don't think his
agenda is to actually invade ukraine at
all there's no way he can win he may be
deluded but he's not he may be
misinformed but i don't think putin is
actually suicidal
and dmitry just finally i wonder what do
you think is the biggest threat to putin
do you think um as we as we've discussed
and it's discussed in the article it is
you know people power um or is it some
of the other things we're talking about
well i think that um there are a number
of things that putin cares about
certainly he wants
stability he wants what he calls managed
democracy which is turning more and more
into
outright autocracy within russia so he
wants no challenge to his regime he
wants to ultimately figure out a way to
retire with a with a
successor that is going to take care of
his interests most likely and and the
one problem with the kazakhstan scenario
is that he has seen the nazarbayev
scenario that he was probably eyeing
with some envy when azerbaijav retired
but still held
hold on to power disintegrated before
his eyes and last week so he's probably
thinking now that he'll have to die in
office and and not trust his successor
to
um to keep him safe
but when it comes to uh the new abroad i
think his interests are to
sort of uh make russia great again if
you will and make sure that russia has
tremendous fear of influence
in the region and that um you know when
it comes to ukraine in particular i
think his interests are twofold one
he absolutely does not want nato
advisors nato weaponry in ukraine i
think owen is absolutely right about
that but he also doesn't want ukraine in
nato i think both are red lines for
russia and he's trying to achieve that
objective right now with a threat of
invasion i still think unlike owen that
invasion is likely because he's not
going to get anywhere on the diplomatic
front and in fact they're cornering
themselves with the rhetoric
particularly with the rhetoric that
rapkov
was talking about the deputy foreign
minister in geneva who was negotiating
with wendy sherman
uh saying that they want ironclad
bulletproof waterproof
guarantees legally binding guarantees
that ukraine will never join nato which
of course the us and nato allies have
rejected just out of hand so when you
when you come in with that strong
position and say that this is your top
priority and you will take nothing less
it makes it very difficult to see how
they achieve any sort of diplomatic
victory and say face domestically or
internationally and i'm very afraid that
they may indeed invade now i agree with
owen they have i think no interest in
annexing
ukraine or any part of ukraine i think
they want to create sort of a puppet
state just like they have in lugansk and
donetsk um and i don't think they'll
take over all of ukraine i don't think
they'll even try to take kiev but i
think they they can uh grab a big chunk
of the eastern ukraine territory up to
the nepal river potentially
thank you dimitri thank you owen
in the january edition of spectator
world mary harrington says the pandemic
has not just revealed but widened class
divides the upper classes can jet off
like kim kardashian did to their own
private island and avoid it all and the
middle classes can work from their
laptops at home or an airbnb
the working class as low she writes have
been forced to keep on working in
restaurants bars and hotels
to discuss mary joins me now
mary for the spectators world january
edition you write a piece where you
begin by talking about a wedding what
was the significance of this wedding
it caused a significant stir across the
united states just for its sheer
extravagance
it was reported in the pages of vogue as
far as i could make out it went on for
at least three days
every single detail of it was wildly
expensive and wildly curated i mean it
was it was mesmerizing it had to sort of
marry antoinette energy about it you
know every every dress cost thousands
every detail of it was just sort of
wildly kind of
symbolic to a to a degree which is
unimaginable i think to most ordinary
people simply because that's just not
the world we live in you know we might
be able to choose whether to go to this
restaurant or that restaurant but the
idea of you know inviting a thousand of
your closest friends to a wedding party
or however many it was and then offering
them iv drips to deal with the hangover
at the after party picnic the following
morning
it was just a bit beyond most people's
normal frame of reference
it was it had a kind of end of
end of civilization kind of
hyper hyper wealthy decadence to it
which i think just struck a very strange
note at the end of a pandemic when a lot
of people have been going through some
really quite grim times
and this is a wedding involving ivy
getty and from the wealthy getty family
but in your piece you make the example
that this is uh you know a sign of how
covert is not just highlighted but
actually exacerbated class divisions um
in society can you talk us through um
almost the various parts of that because
there's one obviously the upper class as
you could call them but there's another
group which is perhaps one that probably
um more people watching this could uh
you know compare their lifestyles to
rather than this wedding
so i
i outlined the ways in which ivy getty's
wedding and also the met gala which was
not long before that exemplified a very
stark division which has been more more
i think revealed than
revealed than anything else by the
pandemic which is to say asymmetric
rules on masking
it's now it's now routine for people who
are serving
others of higher status to remain masked
while people people who command higher
status whether permanently or
temporarily are exempt from that for
whatever reason and one example i gave
was ivy getty's wedding where the
wedding party and nancy pelosi who
officiated swept into the into the town
hall at which point all the all the
attendees all the guests ritually put
their masks on but the wedding party
remained unmasked you know the same was
very visible at the met gala photographs
show that the guests were unmasked but
all the serving people were masked in
uniformly and that was even visible at
the beginning of the pandemic when kim
kardashian tweeted from the private
island where she she arranged a
get-together with all of her extended
family and they were all pictured
hugging and drinking and having a lovely
time while all of us were locked down or
you know saying goodbye to our dying
grandmas through the nursing home window
um meanwhile there are serving staff in
the background collecting empties with
their masks on kim kardashian's private
island so that's so so much for the
aristocracy you know who who are as it
were permanently exempt from masking um
and masking i think stands as a kind of
symbol of status in this way you know
whether or not you whether or not you're
entitled to in-person human interaction
um the zoom class um i've sort of i've
tried to show how
if you're a member of the zoom class
which is to say people who people who do
knowledge work i class myself i suppose
as a member of that class i work
remotely you know i'd my i could take my
laptop and in theory work from anywhere
um
that class
is sometimes sometimes gets to enjoy the
the mask-free privileges of the sort of
kardashians of this world and at other
times don't and are also characterized
by being extraordinarily neurotic
um about about infection control and i
cited as an example um an
article in the atlantic
which reported a man going to a
different wedding um
in new orleans
um where
he panicked all the way through about
the terrible riskiness of of interacting
in in a normal way mask-free despite the
fact that everybody who attended the
wedding parties was already vaccinated
and then as far as i could make out
absolutely freaked out when he caught
covert as a consequence of that and
hired an apartment down the road from
his family where where his children
would come and visit him sitting more
six feet or more away on the porch
wearing and wearing an n95 mask
which suggests a a fairly extreme degree
of of anxiety about contamination which
to my eyes will shades over from being
sort of strictly medical and rational
into something more like a sort of fears
for spiritual purity and i would say
this is this has become increasingly
characteristic of the zoom class
and further down the food chain that
just simply isn't practically possible
because these are the people who are who
are serving you know in all of these
settings you know people who people the
people who collect rubbish bins or do
care work or whatever you know have have
done their best to manage infection
control but if you work with people on a
daily basis as your job and can't work
remotely it's just not possible to
become that neurotic about in-person
human contact it just isn't because you
you remain in contact with people
um just by virtue of the nature of your
work
and i think
it's and what i really wanted to draw
out was
the the way the pandemic has has both
stratified those classes in a much more
extreme way because it's rendered it
it's not only rendered the divisions
more visible but it's also it's also
increased increased the the difficulty
of navigating back and forth between
these classes
yeah it's wide it's widened divisions
between the richest and the poorest i
believe jeff bezos for example um
has added something like you know a
multiple to his to his total wealth well
well plenty of other people just
just went under
and i wanted mary do you think
historically this is surprising i mean
ultimately you i suppose might expect
right or wrong and i think when you say
wrong that the rich will be the people
who manage to have the you know the
least harmed under them in a crisis
often and will be the ones who have the
options when it comes to whether it's a
private island or you know getting away
from something or just making your own
surroundings much more pleasant
i think that's absolutely true you know
it's
i thought the the famous you know the
the rich do what they want or the rich
do what they can and the poor suffer
what they must i think is as the famous
saying has it
um and and that's probably always been
the case but what i really wanted to
draw out in this article was the way
that there's a sort of tragedy at work
um in in terms of how this has played
out within the sort of middling sword
the middle class
um which
[Music]
which has been
undergoing a process of hollowing out
which is which has been detectable not
just in america but across the west for
for some years really since the the
thatcher years
and then the the the economic liberal
the well the the liberalization of
finance and de-industrialization the
migrant outsourcing of industry
all of which has has begun a slow
methodical breaking down of middle-class
prosperity and to and to a significant
extent working-class prosperity as well
across the west in a way which is is is
now increasingly starting
to reveal itself as a very much very
very much starker and more stratified um
stratified class hierarchy you know
across all of these across all of these
geographies where um
moving back and forth across these class
barriers is just considerably more
difficult and what i what i really
wanted to draw out was the irony of
where the resistance is coming from in
the west to
to this
to masking and pandemic control measures
because a lot of it is actually coming
from a sort of the the an older a more
old-fashioned conservative bourgeoisie
many of whom were also um also right
behind the economic reforms which have
which have ended up hollowing out a lot
of the sort of middle class prosperity
um
which is now being replaced by by this
very much more sort of information-led
zoom class
um and much and much thinner middle
class
um whereas increasingly on both sides as
joel copkin points out also in the
january issue um
instead we're seeing something very much
more like a new feudalism
you mentioned the narrowing of the
middle class so if you have the zoom
class and you're talking about the
laptop class you can ultimately go where
they want to do or perhaps aspire to
live the lifestyles you talk about of
the you know the upper classes the
gettys and what's happening to those who
no longer fit into that middle class um
where do they know fit is is that
working class or something else
i mean these these things are obviously
complex and vary a lot by geography but
but i suppose you could you could
characterize
you could characterize a lot of what's
happening and a lot of what what's
happening in the cultural particularly
as a contest between
you know this sort of emerging zoom
class you know the the knowledge class
with the with a portable ish laptop work
that can happen from anywhere in a much
more place-based bourgeoisie you know
which which might be characterized by
small business owners for example or or
people connect people whose
whose prosperity is connected to a
particular geography
such as you know smallholders landowners
small business owners
um
people
who you might characterize i suppose is
a sort of
a sort of old-fashioned yeomanry and
that's the class which is shrinking
and that's and that's the class that you
find lined up behind behind figures such
as donald trump you know with with you
know a certain amount of incoherence um
in in in their argument
and and a certain number you know that
and that brings a certain a number of
contradictions to the fall but but i
think what what we're looking at is a is
a genuine set of class grievances and a
genuine sense of threat at an economic
at a whole sort of economic order and
way of life which is becoming
increasingly increasingly unstable and
is and is being contested by an emerging
new variant of the middle class which
just doesn't have the same commitments
to place
and and has has a wholly different set
of economic interests and i think those
those tensions are really only just
starting to play out and just finally
and on this week's episode we've been
talking a lot about boris johnson the
trouble the government is in and it all
plays into this narrative that we saw
with dominic cummings and barnard castle
of one rule for them and it's been a
really corrosive political narrative in
lots of countries you've seen it in
various governments but i wonder when
we're going back to these mask rules and
talking about the wedding kim
kardashian's holiday
are we just doing a more sophisticated
version of this because there's not so
much of breach of the rules it's almost
a new set of rules the rules almost
designed to allow for this inequality
i certainly don't think that's how
ordinary people perceive it um
i'm not if i'm honest i'm not i mean i
couldn't i couldn't really speculate but
my hunch is it's unlikely to be even how
um
our political leaders see it you know
it's it's
i suspect that some form of masking
rituals and class stratifications will
persist but if you in terms of our
immediate political situation my gut
feel is that actually what's going on is
something more like
they've decided
people have more or less consciously
decided that the pandemic is over or
it's nearly over and they'd like to pin
as much of the collective misery of the
british public and then but everything
we've all undergone over the last year
and a half or two years onto boris
johnson as possible and to designate him
as it were as a kind of sin eater and
just to to pin blame as much of that on
him as possible and then load him up
with the outrage that comes you know
attendant on the fact that he wasn't
even really following the rules himself
and then defenestrate him so that
somebody with relatively clean hands can
be installed you know certainly if i
were a tory politician that's what i'd
be doing um if i wanted to have a have a
fighting chance of winning the next
election and so i i don't really think
there's anything anything sort of large
scale going on about public manners i
suspect it's much more about just brute
politics
um thank you mary and thanks for joining
us today
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you